hey this is presh tolwalker
a quarter Circle contains a circle that
is tangent to one of its sides
construct a line segment perpendicular
to the other side of the quarter Circle
and tangent to the circle inside the
quarter Circle
if this line segment has length equal to
12
find the area that's shaded in blue
which is the area of the quarter Circle
not contained within the small circle
I think monish for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's suppose the quarter Circle has a
radius length equal to a and the small
circle has a radius length equal to B
then the diameter of the small circle is
equal to 2B and that's exactly the
distance between the center of the
quarter Circle and the line segment
we want to calculate the area that's
shaded in blue and that will be equal to
the area of the quarter Circle minus the
area of the small circle
this is equal to Pi a squared over 4
minus pi b squared
factoring out Pi gives pi multiplied by
the quantity a squared over 4 minus B
squared
it remains to solve for a squared over 4
minus P Squared
to do that construct a radius of these
quarter circle to the endpoint of the
line segment
this will have a length equal to a
we now have a right triangle where the
hypotenuse is equal to a and its legs
are equal to 2B and 12.
therefore a squared is equal to the
quantity 2B squared plus 12 squared
simplifying this equation and then
dividing both sides by 4 and then
subtracting B squared from both sides
gives a squared over 4 minus B squared
is equal to 36.
all we need to do now is substitute in
for a squared over 4 minus B squared
so we get the area shaded in blue is
equal to 36 pi
and amazingly we solve for the answer
without knowing the radius of either the
quarter Circle or the small circle
amazing
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign